okay das ist aber in dem fall würden nur
live das ist mit die sonne
ja ich weiß gar nicht wie es mit unserer
micro mach ich das neue an oder aus oder
dass unser eigenes micro brauchen sie
dann ja nicht für die leute die dann
hier vorne stehen sitzen okay da muss
man sehen wenn sie alle leise sind
kriegen wir das hin glaube ich
dann sagen sie wann es losgehen sollen
eigentliche aufnahme
die namen müssen stimmen
oder doch ich sehe schon die nicht und
es ist nichts falsch rum
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
begrüße sie hier im kreishaus des
landkreises vechta zu unserer heutigen
pressekonferenz vielen dank dass sie
sich zeit genommen haben hierher zu
kommen
es geht um das ergebnis der reinen
testung bei der firma oldenburger gefüge
spezialitäten wie wir gestern verwendet
haben sind zuge dieser reinen testung
herausgekommen dass 66 neuinfektionen
dabei identifiziert werden konnten und
aus diesem anlass um auch ihre fragen zu
klären und noch mal die zahlen ein
bisschen genauer zu erläutern
haben wir jetzt diese pressekonferenz
einberufen
ich stelle ihnen einmal kurz vor wer
hier mit auf dem podium ist und beginne
jetzt einfach mal von meiner seite aus
gesehen links ist frau grützner nun ja
kürzer aus dem gesundheitsamt des
landkreises vechta grad winkel der hier
nicht vertreten ist dann peter wesjohann
ist er vorsitzender der
vorstandsvorsitzende der rwe gruppe
daneben haben wir dann herrn doktor
hammerson tochter amazon ist der
stellvertretende leiter des
gesundheitsamtes des landkreises vechta
und ganz links von ihnen aus gesehen
wolga wirkungsstätte kreisrat des
landkreises vechta hat ihren dienst
antrat vor allen dingen zuständig für
den ordnungs reich wir haben für diese
pressekonferenz 60 minuten vorgesehen
und werden gleich anfangen zunächst mit
einem statement von herrn landrat winkel
danach ein statement von herrn wesjohann
und danach können wir dann auch schon in
die frage und antwort runde einsteigen
die ich dann moderiere
dazu dann aber gleich mehr dann übergebe
ich jetzt das wort gerne landrat henkel
ja sagen herzlichen dank ich mache das
jetzt ohne mikrofon sowie besprochen ist
das okay gut ja wir wollten informieren
über den sachstand der standards gesagt
wir haben letzte woche getestet die
testergebnisse liegen mittlerweile vor
und deswegen wollen wir so ein bisschen
auch historisch noch mal sagen wie es
letztendlich dazu gekommen ist
wir haben letztmalig getestet am 26 hier
bei der firma wiesenhof oder ubs heisst
es richtig oder geflügel spezialitäten
dann haben wir getestet am 25.06 und am
16 17
in den ersten beiden testreihen hatten
wir jeweils nur zwei infizierte und in
der letzten test 3 hatten wir stark
angesagt 66 infizierte festgestellt die
firma wiesenhof hat in der vergangenheit
auch in den letzten wochen immer selber
auch getestet immer eine gewisse anzahl
das kann investoren selber besser sagen
als ich und bei diesen testen hat sich
herausgestellt dass in letzter zeit
vermehrt infizierte aufgetreten waren
aus diesem anlass heraus haben wir
gesagt wir wollen eine eigene amtliche
testung durchführen aller beschäftigten
bei wiesenhof und das waren dann
insgesamt also bei der ubs führung
das ist immer noch so drin das waren
insgesamt 1046 die wir getestet haben
und haben 66 fälle dann ermittelt gesamt
waren das dann 35 es kam noch ein
anderer fall dazu and vechta der aber
damit nichts zu tun hat also 35 dann 27
auch wieder plus ein weiterer fall in
diepholz 2 in osnabrück eine in delmas
und einer in cloppenburg also immer
bezogen auf die landkreise oder
kreisfreien städte die inzidenz liegt
nach unseren berechnungen zur zeit war
41 67 weiß dass im internet höhere zahl
mit 44,6
grassieren nach unseren berechnungen ist
aber 41 67 falsch das richtig und das
sind 9 15 einer woche so gesamt
verteilung auf die kommunen würde ich
ihnen auch gerne sagen was der kreis
vechta betrifft das sind 9 in der
gemeinde bakum zwar also von den 67 2 in
damme zwar ein ding klage eine in
goldenstedt das können wir sonst
sicherlich hinterher auch noch mal zur
verfügung stellen dann lohne 40 also da
ist der schwerpunkt im moment in vechta
9 und in visbek 4
das müsste dann insgesamt 67 ergeben wir
haben kinder dabei elf kinder unter 18
jahre wir haben allerdings den vorteil
moment dass wir ja ferien haben so dass
wir wegen der schulen keine maßnahmen
unternehmen müssen das sind zwei
kindergartenkinder noch dabei in baku da
müssen wir sehen die gehen natürlich
nicht in die krippe morgen in den
kindergarten und deswegen müssen
natürlich gucken wie wir jetzt damit
umgehen aber das wird dann morgen hin
mehr passieren von den 66 fällen die wir
festgestellt haben sind 27 in der
frühschicht 43 in der spätschicht und
einer in der nachtschicht davon sind ja
das sind die 66 die mussten sich daraus
ergeben wir haben natürlich geguckt wo
kommen denn die infizierten eigentlich
her weil wir versuchen natürlich auch
zusammenhänge herzustellen war ja wir
herausfinden wollen wo kommen die
infektionen her
wir haben insgesamt 1284 mitarbeiter
gesamt werden sich natürlich wundern
warum wir nur 1000 was man das 64 46
getestet haben
das liegt daran dass natürlich urlauber
dabei sind das kranke menschen dabei
sind das menschen dabei sind die
quarantäne sind insofern ergibt sich
dann diese zeit ja von der zuordnung
hier haben uns natürlich gefragt wie
kann das letztendlich sein wir haben mit
der firma ubs seit wochen eigentlich
kann man sagen dass hygiene konzept
immer weiter ausgefeilt sie wissen dass
die firma ogs ja ein neues werk gebaut
hat nach dem brandschaden den wir hatten
und einzelheiten dazu kann sicherlich
west jahren sagen
und insofern haben wir es mit einem ganz
modernen werk zu tun dass auch die
modernsten lüftungs anforderungen hat
wir haben festgestellt dass in einem
karton lager wo eigentlich die
mitarbeiter zwei bis drei meter
auseinander sind an den arbeitsplätzen
das wäre aber trotzdem dort ein
geschehen mit sieben infizierten die
vermutung besteht dass gegebenenfalls
dort in den pausen oder im haushalt
pausen wie auch immer man sich
gegebenenfalls dort zusammen getroffen
hat und dann die abstände nicht
eingehalten hat das werden wir auch zum
anlass nehmen weiter an dem hygiene
konzept zu feilen das heißt also auch da
hin zu gucken wie ist das in den pausen
da wird zusätzliches personal eingesetzt
was guckt dass die abstände entsprechend
eingehalten wird aber das kann ja was
werden auch gleich sagen
bei den anderen bereichen die ich ihnen
genannt habe sind
bestimmte massierung von infektionen
nicht zuordenbar das heißt wir haben
verschiedene bereiche in denen
gearbeitet wird und sie haben
verschiedene arbeits tätigkeiten und
außer im karton lange haben wir keine
massierung in bestimmten bereichen
festgestellt
die firma ubs hat ja die jeder maßnahme
selber auch umgesetzt in abstimmung bei
uns wie ich bereits gesagt habe und da
hat man natürlich frühzeitig auch daran
gearbeitet dass eben kontakte vermied
werden dass die gene konzepte
eingehalten werden das nasa gearbeitet
wird alle diese dinge
insofern ist es schwierig zuzuordnen
wurde eine infektion herkommen wir haben
uns daraufhin gestern und heute genau
wie die diepholzer kollegen auch die
haushalte der infizierten angesehen
haben insgesamt 70 personen in
quarantäne gesetzt was der landkreis
vechta betrifft in die polizei uns
nochmal das hat mir gesagt 64 groß ist
immer nach klopp 64 und das waren in
vielen fällen einzelhaushalte und keine
sogenannte massen unterkünfte
das heißt wir gehen vielfach davon aus
das ist schwer zu ermitteln muss man
auch ganz deutlich sagen weil es
natürlich sich nicht immer um
deutschsprachige mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter handeln da kommen oft hansen
aussagen
wir sind immer zu hause wir achten auf
die hygiene die abstände werden
eingehalten
aber vom gesamtbild her kann das
eigentlich nicht sein so dass wir davon
ausgehen dass die größten teile sich
wahrscheinlich privat infiziert haben
über kontakte da hängt es auch zusammen
mit familien mit lebenspartnerschaften
und mit zusammenhängen was man in der
freizeit gemeinsam macht diese dinge
davon gehen wir zumindest aus wir haben
gesagt dass wir dieses
infektionsgeschehen genau beobachten
wollen das heißt wir werden
voraussichtlich mitte dieser woche eine
weitere testung vornehmen aller
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter um das
weiter einzugrenzen und weiter zu sehen
wo sind der mögliche infektionsherde wo
sich mögliche effekte
uns geschehen und das haben wir mit der
firma auch so abgestimmt
die pausenräume soll noch mal besonders
behandelt werden desinfiziert werden
aber das kann der westen im einzelnen
dazu sagen
und wir müssen uns genau angucken
darüber sind uns auch einig die frage
der reiserückkehrer sie wissen dass
moment viele natürlich in urlaub fahren
ist viele in ihre heimatländer fahren
und das von daher dann natürlich bei der
rückkehr geguckt werden muss aus diesen
ländern bringt man gegebenenfalls
infektionen mit packt man die menschen
erst mal wenn sie erstmal nicht arbeiten
während sie getestet
und wie geht man damit um das ist ein
großes problem was auf ihn zukommt ja so
weit vielleicht erst mal aus meiner
sicht von meiner seite ich würde gerne
weitergeben
ein invest währung getauscht einfach die
plätze fragen haben
meine schüler tauschen wasser
ja meine damen meine herren
schönen guten tag auch von meiner seite
von meiner seite möchte ich zunächst mal
das bedauern zum ausdruck bringen
seitens auch im namen der bürger
geflügel spezialitäten aber auch im
namen meiner familie über die jedoch
gehäuften fälle von kobe 19 infektionen
bei den mitarbeitern der oldenburger
geflügel spezialitäten
ich möchte betonen dass die gesundheit
unserer mitarbeiter und ihre angehörigen
oberste priorität haben
und da unterscheide ich auch nicht ob es
jetzt mitarbeitern fest angestellten
verhältnisse sind oder werk
vertragsverhältnis oder ob es
arbeitnehmerüberlassung ist und aus
welchen ländern
diese mitarbeiter kommen sind alle
wichtig wir nehmen die situation sehr
ernst und mich persönlich aber insgesamt
beruhigt beunruhigt uns das
infektionsgeschehen insofern bin ich
auch herrn landrat winkel dankbar hier
heute durchaus unser konzept bei der ubs
oder geflügel spezialitäten mal
darstellen zu können
vielleicht vorweg wir haben die
mitarbeiter die in garantie infiziert
sind und in quarantäne sind und die noch
zusätzlich in quarantäne geschickt
worden sind haben wir von unserer von
der oldenburger geflügel spezialitäten
alle informiert auch in der jeweiligen
landessprache was quarantäne bedeutet
wie die verhaltensregeln sein sollen
in der so dass es das ich hoffe dass da
auch dann tatsächlich die quarantäne
optimal eingehalten wird
außerdem ist es so dass die versorgung
der mitarbeiter durch die ubs oder deren
werk vertragspartner sichergestellt wird
so dass wir da auch entsprechend die
versorgung dieser leute von uns aus
sicherstellen werden und ich hoffe
natürlich dass wenn es zu
krankheitsverläufen käme dass die
natürlich so verlaufen dass die
mitarbeiter
möglichst schnell wieder gesund werden
was das infektionsgeschehen angeht ist
es so dass wir bei der rückverfolgung
des infektionsgeschehen eng mit den
behörden mit dem landkreis zusammen
arbeiten und zusammen gearbeitet haben
und das bedeutet auch mit vollkommener
transparenz
das bedeutet auch bezüger übermittlung
der kontaktdaten so dass wir da
tatsächlich auch möglichst schnell
handeln können wenn es notwendig wird
oder die behörden auch schnell handeln
können wenn es denn notwendig wird
hinsichtlich des hygiene und pandemie
konzeptes der oldenburger geflügel
spezialitäten möchte ich ihnen mitteilen
dass wir dieses konzept was sehr
detailliert ist zum einen mit dem
gewerbeaufsichtsamt zu anderen zum an
damit der berufsgenossenschaft und dann
vor allem auch mit dem gesundheitsamt
und im landkreis vechta abgestimmt haben
weil wir alle ein gemeinsames ziel haben
die infektionen und die infektionsketten
schnell zu identifizieren und zu
unterbrechen
aber bei hähnchen schlachterei
vielleicht mal eines vorweg ist die
schlachtung und zerlegung vollkommen
automatisiert das ist anders als bei
anderen tierarten das vollkommen
automatisiert so dass danach leichte
schneidearbeiten verpackungsarbeiten und
kommission ihr arbeiten noch tätig
werden
das ist vielleicht im bezug auf die
öffentliche diskussion wichtig zu wissen
wir haben diesen betrieb in lohne nach
dem brand nach den neuesten modernsten
erkenntnissen aufgebaut wieder und wir
haben dort mit sicherheit ein betrieb
stehen der weltweit einer der modernsten
hähnchen schlachthöfe
ist wenn ich sogar der modernste
schlachthof weltweit und das auch im
hinblick auf die lüftung die da
eingebaut worden ist das nur vorweg wir
haben ein bei der lüftung eine
frischluftzufuhr von 25 25 prozent und
die umluft wird über filter in
speziellen verfahren entkeimt so dass da
tatsächlich dann auch die lüftungs
voraussetzungen wie gewünscht auch
erfüllt werden in diesem betrieb und 1
möchte ich auch noch sagen die
mitarbeiter ob es jetzt fest angestellte
oder werkvertrags beschäftigte oder
leiharbeiter sind die arbeiten alle
unter den gleichen bedingungen und
entsprechenden abständen was dass die
hygiene angeht ist es ja so sind wir in
der lebensmittelproduktion stetig und
wir arbeiten mit fleisch das heißt wir
müssen von jeher so oder so eine top
jene haben und schon vor corinna zeiten
haben wir einen extrem hochwertiges
hygiene konzept gehabt das heißt zum
einen dass wir jederzeit ausreichende
und professionelle sturz schutzkleidung
bei den mitarbeitern haben wie
schutzanzüge mundschutz kopfhaube und
auch die gene schuhe also und kann sagen
sie sind von kopf bis fuß ihr seit jeher
eingekleidet die mitarbeiter und
erfüllen schon von daher auch schon die
krone bedingungen außerdem wird jeder an
allen ständen ausreichend
desinfektionsmittel zur verfügung
gestellt wenn mitarbeiter den betrieb
betreten oder in einzelne segmente des
betriebes gehen möchten es so werden sie
durch eine zwangs schleuse geführt das
heißt wir müssen erst händewaschen und
desinfizieren und erst dann gibt er der
automat den zugang zu gewissen
teilbereich oder den die betrieb frei
und um auch sprachbarrieren zu
überwinden ist es so dass wir laufend
hygieneschulungen machen
verpflichtende e-learning schulung
aushänge aber auch die mitarbeiter über
in deren landessprache über monitore
ständig in deren muttersprache
informieren
als jetzt der korona virus nach
deutschland kam haben wir dieses hygiene
konzept nochmals intensiviert wir haben
alle beschäftigten nochmals auf dieses
intensive hygiene konzept eingeschult
haben alle beschäftigten hinsichtlich
möglicher ansteckungsfähigkeit mit dem
corona virus als auch mit mögliche
auftreten der symptome bei erkrankungen
sensibilisiert zudem haben wir damals
vor monaten zusätzliche pausen räume
geschaffen so dass die einhaltung der
abstandsregelung gewährleistet ist und
zum anderen sind auch die
arbeitsschichten komplett getrennt
worden um potenzielle ansteckungen
zwischen den geschichten so gering wie
möglich zu halten
darüber hinaus ist es so dass wir wenn
beschäftigte aus risikogebieten die vom
staat aus als risikogebiete ausgewiesen
werden
eine 14 tägige vorsorglicher quarantäne
pflicht eingeführt haben bevor sie
wieder in betrieb arbeiten können die
mitarbeiter urlaubsrückkehrer
neueingestellte leute die aus quarantäne
com oder auch aus krankheit kommen
werden vorher getestet und müssen
negativ sein bevor sie den betrieb
wieder betreten dürfen und werden circa
vier tage später nochmals getestet
außerdem ist innerhalb des betriebes der
abstand gewährt da wo das etwas etwas
enger werden könnte haben wir auch
entsprechende kunststoff abtrennungen im
gesamten betrieb eingearbeitet so dass
dann noch mal eine zusätzliche
sicherheit für die mitarbeiter gegeben
sein dürfte
und wir haben uns zumindest was die
würstchen transport der mitarbeiter aus
den werkvertrags beschäftigten
verhältnissen vom von den unterkünften
werkvertrags arbeitgeber zur verfügung
gestellt hat auch noch mal angeguckt
dass da der abstand in den transport
gegebenheiten auch gewahrt wird und auch
mit mundschutz
der winkel hatte das schon angesprochen
wir haben selber risiko basierte tests
durchgeführt und werden dies auch
zukünftig weiter durchführen
dass es gibt noch viele viele andere
maßnahmen in anbetracht der der der
situation ist führt das jetzt wäre das
jetzt so viel alles alles hier
darzulegen
aber die früheren großflächen testung
haben gezeigt aus meiner sicht dass wir
seit beginn der krise bis vor kurzem
auch das infektionsgeschehen durchaus
bei der ubs im griff hatten und auch aus
meiner sicht auch noch im griff haben
was den betrieb angeht aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist es so gibt es
weitere maßnahmen die wir nochmal
ausgearbeitet haben wir werden die
anzahl der risikobasierten basierten
tests noch einmal intensivieren die
nächsten monate wir haben vorher schon
aber machen es nochmal flächendeckende
komplett desinfektion der der der
schlachterei durchführen
wir haben oder werden noch einmal
zusätzliches personal zur verfügung
stellen was in den pausenräumen
tatsächlich dann auch nochmals auf die
abstände der einzelnen leute innerhalb
der pausenräume achtet die sind abstände
sind können eingehalten werden das muss
nur gemacht werden intensiv gemacht
werden und da achten wir zusätzliches
personal noch mal drauf achten
und dann gibt es schon den
angesprochenen kartonagen bereich wo
durchaus einige positive fälle sind wo
ich davon ausgehen muss dass da
tatsächlich trotz der thematik dass die
leute drei meter auseinander sind und
auch komplett eingekleidet sind dass da
vielleicht ein fehlverhalten vorliegt
auch da werden wir zusätzliches personal
zur verfügung stellen um einfach die
kontrolle noch zu intensivieren wobei
man muss sagen der kartonagen bereich
ist kein kälte bereich das ist ein
bereich wo er wärme ist als kälte ja wir
versuchen alles von uns aus das
geschehen im griff zu behalten und dass
alle möglichen anstrengungen da in
dieser richtung übernommen also wir
werden alles in unserer macht stehende
tun
schönen dank
zunächst mal für die aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr winkl fielen
wenn ich die gleiche aufrufe einmal kurz
ihren namen sagen das medium die fenster
hier unsere lokalen mit regionalen
medienvertreter aber doch nicht alle
leute da sind und die anderen auf dem
podium auch wir waren einmal dass ich
hier vorne an
dann kommt erschwert sie und sein
hersteller
im leben geben könnte mit leuten die
jetzt mit ihrem heimatland sind wieder
zurückgekommen
wie wollen sie das das regel in das da
kann auch danach den sie
wiederzubekommen wollen vernünftig
[Musik]
also die komplettes infektion machen wir
regelmäßig machen wir jetzt
das wird immer über das wochenende
gemacht so dass wir da keinen stillstand
des betriebes haben dass sie eine frage
das andere ist ich hatte das eben schon
angesprochen urlaubsrückkehrer oder
rückkehrer aussehen aus den jeweiligen
ländern werden bei uns bevor sie in den
betrieb kommen werden sie frei getestet
das heißt sie müssen erst ein negatives
testergebnis vorliegen haben sonst
kommen die nicht in betrieb rein und
wenn sie frei sind kommen sie rein
aber es wird auch trotzdem noch mal vier
tage später circa vier tage später
nochmal nach getestet dann in dem moment
ob sie dann auch weiter frei sind so
dass wir da versuchen das risiko so weit
wie möglich zu minimieren
wir wechseln
[Musik]
ja ich bin gefragt worden was nicht
unbedingt unerwartet war warum wir jetzt
die fälle gehabt haben in geestland also
den landkreis oldenburg und was ist der
unterschied
ich kann ihnen natürlich nicht sagen
warum der landrats kollege in landkreis
oldenburg aufgrund welcher fakten und
welcher tatsachen er entschieden hat den
betrieb zu schließen das weiß ich nicht
natürlich hat man darüber gesprochen
aber die einzelnen details muss ja
jeweiligen landkreis selbst abwägen und
insgesamt ist es eine messens prozess
das heißt ich muss einmal sehen wie ist
die infektions lage insgesamt wie sind
gegebenenfalls menschen gefährdet in
ihrer gesundheit und zum anderen hat
natürlich außer betrieb eine rolle zu
spielen und dann guckt man in erster
linie wo kommt die infektion her ich
habe das vorhin gesagt dass wir uns das
genau angeguckt haben dass wir die
schichten verglichen haben dass wir
geguckt haben waren die menschen alle
zusammen beschäftigt waren sie getrennt
beschäftigt kann man die zusammenhänge
her leiten wo wohnen sie frau kurz da
zum beispiel hat ganze listen mit
straßen zusammengestellt sowohl im
landkreis vechta landkreis diepholz muss
das selber machen aber das noch mal
sieht wo sind gegebenenfalls auch
kontaktmöglichkeiten wo sind adressen
die relativ nah zusammen liegen dass man
sich besuchen kann dass man vielleicht
abends zusammen etwas macht wohl jene
regeln dann vielleicht nicht so beachtet
werden wie wir uns das vorstellen wie es
vorgehen ist und ich kann im moment nur
sagen dass wir nach unserem hygiene
konzept und denen dass wir im betrieb
wissen und der doktor amazon als
mediziner ist ja heute auch hier dass
wir nicht feststellen können dass es
einen bestimmten infektionsherd gibt so
und ich habe mich natürlich sowohl eine
einrichtung als auch in der anderen
richtung einer verhältnismäßigkeit
messen zu lassen und dementsprechend
muss ich beurteilen ob sie soweit sind
dass der betrieb gegebenfalls
beschlossen werden müsste oder nicht
wenn wir jetzt einen speziellen herd
hätten wir haben über das karton lager
besprochen da haben
gesagt was die maßnahmen die wir
unternehmen können wir haben gesagt wir
testen auch weiter verwässern will auch
dessen so dass man versucht zu gucken
gibt es da wirklich irgendwo ein ehrt
nach menschlichem ermessen das ist
natürlich immer nur nach menschlichem
ermessen nach heutiger sicht kann man
sagen dass wir nicht wissen dass
spezielle infektionsherde in der firma
selber sind also habe ich auch keinen
grund dafür im moment den betrieb zu
schließen
und deswegen werde ich das auch nicht
veranlassen zu der zweiten frage was die
instanz betrifft wir beachten dass
natürlich mit argusaugen das können sie
sich denken und die 50er marke marke zu
reißen wäre für den landkreis vechta
natürlich schwierig wir wissen auf der
anderen seite und das haben wir auch
heute noch mal angeguckt es gibt ja
dieses urteil des
oberverwaltungsgerichts in münster was
ganz klar gesagt hat man muss dann auf
die räumlichkeiten gucken dass alle
museen wo können gewisse
infektionsgeschehen ist hier herkommen
und wo können sie sich ausbreiten und
dann müsste man entsprechend reagieren
das heißt wir würden dann in dem fall
der hoffentlich nicht eintritt dann
würden wir sehen wo haben wir die
massierung an wohnungen zum beispiel wo
sind diese menschen wo sind diese
menschen quarantäne welche maßnahmen
muss man dann unternehmen um
gegebenenfalls dann ja ausgangssperren
oder wie auch immer dann örtlich
begrenzt aber dann einzuführen und nicht
für den gesamten landkreis
erst mal bauen
werden
ja vielleicht fange ich mal an weil ich
ja gerade hier sitze also wir haben uns
die pausenräume natürlich vom hygiene
konzept er auch angesehen es sind haben
wir auch dazu gesagt vermutung es ist
nicht so wie sie gerade gesagt haben
dass jetzt die leute sich in den
pausenräumen angesteckt haben sondern es
sind vermutungen wir wissen die
infektionsherde nicht wir haben in der
firma keine gefunden es ist eine
vermutung wegen dieser massierung der
sieben leute in dem karton bereich also
kartonagen bereich den anderen haben wir
das nicht gefunden und wir haben die
pausenräume unseren vornherein angesehen
weil wir ja auch wussten aus anderen
geschehnissen dass da durchaus ein
problem sein kann und es war auch schon
meines wissens aber das muss ja was
hören was zu sagen
auch ein entsprechender ordnungsdienste
unterwegs wo geguckt wurde dass die
leute sich entsprechend da nicht zu nahe
kommen und auch nicht treffen
andere aussagen müssen sie letztendlich
dazu treffen warum fleischbranche wir
haben in der vergangenheit auch in
anderen branchen durchaus massierung
gehabt die natürlich nicht so auf
ploppen wie jetzt bei ogs hier liegt ist
ein eigentlich daran dass wir mit einem
mit 1046 oder dass man insgesamt 1200
und noch mehr mitarbeitern ein sehr
großes unternehmen haben wenn sie jetzt
andere unternehmen sehen die sind
teilweise viel kleiner und da haben sie
auch andere bevölkerungsanteile durchaus
die dort arbeiten und die vielleicht an
hygieneregeln besser einhalten muss man
natürlich immer sehr vorsichtig sein mit
der beurteilung solcher fragen und von
daher also wir haben es im paketbereich
zum beispiel gehabt wo massierung
aufgetreten sind wo ähnliche bereiche
betroffen waren und andere auch deswegen
kann man das nicht ausschließt so sagen
nur hier war es jetzt natürlich durch
die anzahl der fälle einer massierung in
dem bereich hat er auch berichtet von
den ersten beiden testen wo er jeweils
bei über 1000 leuten nur zwei infizierte
hatten
und das ließ ja nicht darauf schließen
dass wir ein problem haben wenn der
freistaat
wir tauschen
also das 4
wir haben bei den pausenräumen schon
schon personal die dass die die
einhaltung der abstände kontrolliert die
pausenräume sind so ausgestattet dass
die abstände eingehalten werden können
das ist eine reine zusätzliche
vorsichtsmaßnahme und das hat nichts
damit zu tun dass das
infektionsgeschehen da da aufgetreten
ist dass die eine seite zweite seite ist
nochmal kantine haben wir bei der
oldenburger geflügelschlachterei so in
der form nicht um das auch noch mal zu
sagen dann wie wir das contract
kontrollieren ja da werden wir uns
externe hilfe personelle hilfe besorgen
die schule natürlich auch entsprechend
das ist klar und können davon ausgehen
dass wir das geschultes personal dann
dann zur verfügung stellen die auch dann
mit der zusätzlichen
sicherheitsüberprüfungen würde ich das
mal ein zusätzlicher
sicherheitsüberwachung dann auch
beauftragt werden
warum fleischindustrie
ja es ist gut wir haben ungefähr über
200.000 infizierte in deutschland ich
glaube wenn man mal die zahl der fleisch
der der fälle in der fleischindustrie
ansieht dann ist das sicherlich eine
gewisse zahl aber die anderen fälle sind
natürlich auch in irgendwelchen
industrien tätig also es ist nicht nur
die fleischindustrie kann man vielleicht
nicht ganz so sagen aber es erfolgen
natürlich innerhalb der fleischindustrie
auch viele testung vielleicht auch mehr
als in anderen branchen
weitere fragen ihrer seite
das vorstellen
ja das infektionsgeschehen hat zwar
nichts mit werkvertrag zu tun aber ich
sag sie trotzdem
also wir haben bei der ubs eine
betriebsvereinbarung mit dem betriebsrat
vorliegen wo wir bis zu 40% werkverträge
außerhalb der krise einsetzen dürfen
und vielleicht haben sie es mitbekommen
wir haben ja vor geraumer zeit eine
pressemeldung noch raus gegeben dass wir
bis zum 11 2010 21
die werkvertrags beschäftigten auch alle
in ein fest angestelltes
arbeitsverhältnis überführen werden
da werden die konzeption jetzt
ausgearbeitet und dann zu gegebener zeit
kann ich ihnen das auch auskunft zu
geben
weitere fragen
ich sehe das ist nicht der fall wenn es
auch noch keine ergänzungen jetzt hier
gibt vom beschuldigungen können
wir können sie wissen wir kennen uns
schon länger wie das ganze geht die
armen moment unter 50 und ich hoffe auch
dass es unter 50 bleibt so in dem fall
werden die üblichen hygienemaßnahmen
eingehalten die wir der bevölkerung auch
über ihre zeitung
ständig versuchen nahe zu bringen und im
übrigen bands richtung 50 oder übergehen
sollte wenn wir sicherlich im einzelnen
sehen auch mit den bürgermeistern sich
alice der beteiligten oder betroffenen
städte und gemeinden was im einzelnen zu
tun ist das ist dann auch wieder
abwägungsprozess nehmen wir vornehmen
werden
und was einen infektionsgeschehen dann
dort ist wissen wir zurzeit natürlich
nicht genau wie das andere eben auch
blick in die zukunft ist ob sie eintritt
oder nicht wissen wir auch nicht
und ich habe nur gesagt dass ich
aufgrund des urteils für den fall der
fälle sage dass wir uns die geschehnisse
sehr genau angucken werden und natürlich
unter zugrundelegung dieser leitsätze
dann auch entscheiden werden was wir tun
jetzt sehe ich aber keine weiteren
fragen mehr doch er wird man all
geschossen
wir haben alle enge kontaktpersonen
ermittelt
70 hatte ich ja vorhin genannt und die
sind teilweise bis zu drei mal
angefahren worden
sie sind alle in quarantäne gesetzt
worden so weit wie sie natürlich
ermitteln konnten und die restlichen
arbeiten werden am montag folgen unsere
leute sind ja auch dann die ganzen tage
rund um die uhr meter weniger im einsatz
das muss natürlich auch handelbar seien
bei diesen zahlen und aber sie sind alle
in quarantäne gesetzt so dass da
eigentlich nach menschen die am essen im
moment nichts passieren kann wir haben
ja viele fälle auch gab die dann in
quarantäne gesetzt waren und die sie in
der quarantäne dann symptomatisch
herausgestellt haben
also die kontaktpersonen sind ermittelt
sie werden üblicherweise nur getestet
wenn sie auch symptom am oder peters
wollte
also wir testen nicht frei weitere
fragen muss der runde dass ihr ich jetzt
nicht jetzt kommt doch ergänzung vom
podium
sehe ich auch nicht doch eine frage was
sagen sie testen so zu sagen ich wenn es
keine symptome gibt die große
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ist ein sozialer
führungsstil unkritischer kann man dazu
etwas sagen
in diesem fall also der kollege davon
hat sie gerade schon punkt angesprochen
ich will das auch mal erwähnt diese 70
kontaktperson stehen natürlich bei uns
lediglich beziehungsweise 2 täglich
unter kontrolle also die werden
spätestens alle zwei tage durch unsere
mitarbeiter kontaktiert
wir ermitteln ob symptome auftreten oder
nicht und wenn symptome auftreten werden
sich auch unmittelbar getestet also das
war bisher immer die strategie und jetzt
auch so bleiben
genau die dunk also es ist so dass wir
natürlich erwarten dass von diesen 70
kontakt her so und die relativ enge
kontaktpersonen sind weil sie
zusammenwohnen
doch ein gewisser teil ich würde von
10 20 leute sicherlich auch noch positiv
werden wir haben ähnliche erfahrungen
gemacht
vor drei wochen als geestland ja
sozusagen die probleme hat wo wir auch
viele betroffene hier bei uns im
landkreis hatte und da haben wir die
gleiche ist das nun her seit vier wochen
versuchen also kann er wirklich etwas zu
sagen
jürgen stetter hatte kontakt zu
gütersloh
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
dann kreis gütersloh war das stichwort
wir haben in der letzten woche kontakt
aufgenommen mit gütersloh um uns
insbesondere beim thema testzentrum
schildern zu lassen wie die situation in
gütersloh abgearbeitet worden ist wie
das thema testzentrum es gab ja meines
wissens acht verschiedene standorte wo
getestet werden konnte ich habe selbst
in den nachrichten gesehen so ein video
mitschnitt wo letztlich durch sonne
ich nenne das flughafen hangar gefahren
werden konnte und dann in
anführungsstrichen die frei testung für
den urlaub erfolgte das ist ein thema
was uns beschäftigt hat die kollegen aus
gütersloh haben mir aber auch mitgeteilt
dass das nicht der hauptgrund gewesen
ist sondern letztlich auch es darum ging
zu ermitteln wie hoch ist in
anführungsstrichen der infizierung grad
in der bevölkerung das ist ein thema
testzentrum mit dem wir uns beschäftigt
haben wenn es dazu kommen sollte werden
wir entsprechend gerüstet sein
wir haben ja auch eine entsprechende
kapazität vor ort um ein testzentrum
kurzfristig einzurichten das haben wir
schon mal gemacht
weitere fragen offen problem sich nichts
dann einfach eine stätte für das sie
heute ich jetzt kommen sie noch eine
bitte falls sie sich nicht in die
anmeldeliste eingetragen haben
bitte holen sie das noch nach damit wir
aber noch weitere presseinformationen
dann kann sie heute auch noch
verschieben können
ansonsten wünsche ich ihnen trotz der
lage einige und sonntag und eine gute
heimfahrt dankeschön
bitte den mutterschutz ausgetragen